how do you get Frank s to be a guest if
he didn't talk to the press and he's
famous for not talking how do you get
him to be a guest on a three-hour talk
show yeah how'd you do that with no
phone calls I Didn't Do It Jackie did it
oh I'm at Jackie's house and there were
a bunch of people there and Jackie would
pose questions so there was a doctor
there and he said to the doctor what in
your business or industry or profession
is impossible what's impossible and I
remember the doctor said they'll never
invent blood in a
laboratory they they make plasma from
blood but they'll never in no one will
ever come up with a compound that will
say here's blood put it in your body and
it'll replace blood right Jackie said
okay that the doctor says guaranteed no
matter how much technolog they'll never
be and he says to me what's impossible
in your profession and I said what I
give it impossible Frank Sinatra is
opening at the font BL uh this coming
week and uh he will not do a local radio
show for 3 hours and this is Top of the
World Frank and G said I'll never forget
it what what night is he off what night
doesn't he work I said Mondays he
doesn't work next Monday all right you
got him next Monday and he delivered
wait a minute hold it I I said what' you
say he said you got him next Monday
night I said wait a I'm going to go do
my radio show now and I'm going to
promote the fact that next
Monday to three hours of talk no phone
calls three hours of talk he said pal
you got them and jaie could get that way
are you questioning me like I said okay
yeah I go back to the radio station it's
like Tuesday next Monday night Frank sin
yeah people are calling sure like
getting the Beatles right yeah now
Friday the management manage I love
management management calls me in listen
Larry we're taking a full page ad in the
Miami heral Sunday pressure saying that
Frank is on your show tomorrow night now
we've called the font blue just to
verify it and we've left 10 messages
nobody's returned to call
uh and so we're a little scared there's
a big ad will you call see if he's
coming so I called
gleon and he calls me back he was
playing golf played golf every day he
called me back and he said yeah what you
know like he could be abrupt what I said
Frank the Sinatra thing what about it
and like I said oh no you didn't forget
I said well you remember Sinatra's on
Monday night yeah what I said well the
station's taken an that he said what do
I care I says well they've been called
he not sure me
did I tell you he's coming he's coming
wow you know he was mad at me like I was
questioning him right I said it's not me
Jackie it's the station he say go don't
then he hung up okay now it's the next
night no one went home from the radio
station The Secret you it's hard to
believe to a younger audience how big
Frank was but I will tell you this I'll
make the analogy to The Beatles like
there is no one currently now bigger
than he was at that time now it's 5 to
99 I go on at 5 after 9 right after the
news it's 5: to 9 the Secretary State
the salesman everybody's there and no
Sinatra and it was a pretty no Sinatra
now a limo pulls in and we could see
right down the wind it was a pretty
station and outstep Sinatra with a guy a
PR guy I guess and he comes up the
stairs we're all standing there and he
just goes uh which one's Larry King I
raised my hand sheepishly yeah he said
okay snaps his fingers let's go right we
go into the studio he sits down I sit
down the pr guy says to me we're walking
down the hall I don't know how the hell
you got this he he pays me not to get
him this so I sit down and I began I
said good evening welcome to the Larry
King show my guest is Frank Sinatra why
are you
here and uh he said well about uh about
3 years ago I was at Ben maxic Town and
Country Club in New York it was Saturday
night closing night and I had laryngitis
I was really bad and we had a packed
house and I couldn't do any make updates
so I called called up Jackie and I said
Jackie was the biggest thing on
television would you would you come and
sit in for me for an hour and said
Jackie came and did a whole bit and did
monologue talk to the audience and saved
me and I walked him out to his car and I
leaned in and I said Jackie I owe you
one wow so when I got to Miami I get a
message called Jackie so I called Jackie
and I said Jackie it's Frank and he said
Frank this is the one wow fact that
Jackie GLE did that one thing for you is
amazing hold the
de